es ist ein kalter Wintermorgen in Iowa
wo die meisten Republikaner Donald Trump
für den einzig richtigen halten aber
Kelly newvenhaus sieht das anders er
will bei den Vorwahlen am Montag ein
Signal setzen dass ihn Freundschaften
kosten könnte zweimal hat der 64-Jährige
Farmer Trump gewählt jetzt reicht
sie es ist Zeit voranzugehen das Chaos
das in den letzten Jahren angerichtet
wurde ist einer der wichtigsten Gründe
dass ich zu Nicki Haley
tendiere wirtschaftlich läuft es gut für
ihn die Ernte Soja und Mais bringt jedes
Jahr gutes Geld Kelly will nicht dass
Amerika aus den Fugen gerät durch Wut
und Hass zwischen politischen Lagern und
auch innerhalb seiner
Partei es war ein jahrelanger
Zirkus ich will einfach nur eine
die welisen kann und in den Gesprächen
dann entschlossen und stark ist sass die
Vereinten Staaten als mächtige Nation
gesehen werden das geht auch ohne gemein
zu
sein selbst im härtesten Wahlkampf so
sieht es Kelly blieb Nicki haly immer
sachlich als ehemalige Gouverneurin von
South Carolina danach usbotschafterin
bei den Vereinten Nationen hat sie innen
und außenpolitische
letztere fehlt rontis dem Gouverneur von
Florida am liebsten würden er und hay
die Wähler mit ihren politischen Ideen
überzeugen aber ein Thema ein nameahme
überschattet einfach
alles wir müssen Präsident Trump hinter
uns lassen und sehen wie wir Amerika
stärken die Wahl sollte sich nicht um
Trump und die vergangenheithen sonderid
versagente in Iowa wo die meisten
Republikaner Donald Trump für den
einzigen Heilsbringer halten in den
Umfragen liegt der 30% vor desantis und
haey obwohl oder gerade weil er bei
seinen Auftritten seine Mitbewerber
beschimpft Gegner zu Feinden des Volkes
erklärt und hier in su City mit der
absoluten Macht
kokettiert ich werde ein Diktator sein
für einen Tag um das ölbohren zu
erlauben und die Grenze zu schließen
danach will ich kein Diktator sein
eigentlich ging die individuelle
Freiheit gerade Republikanern immer über
alles nun glauben sie ihm wenn er den
Untergang Amerikas beschwört und sich zu
ihrer Rettung ermächtigen will er wird
das Land wieder zu dem machen was es mal
war es ist in einem schrecklichen
Zustand alle übervorteilen
uns das Land ist im Chaos wir brauchen
jemanden der stark ist
der Ruf nach dem starken Mann lässt
Beobachter in beiden Parteien Schaudern
Cornel Belcher ehemaliger Berater von
Präsident Obama hält Trumps Worte nicht
für leere
Drohungen er redet davon politische
Gegner festzunehmen und in Lager zu
stecken er will sich auf ein
Notstandsgesetz berufen und dann
Soldaten überall im Land in Großstädte
schicken das hört sich für mich wirklich
nach Diktatur
an Trump ist nicht nur eine große Gefahr
er wäre sogar tödlich für die Demokratie
wenn er gewinnt es ist möglich dass es
wieder nur vier Jahre voller
Regierungsunfähigkeit würden aber ein
Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten hat
eine große Macht nicht nur hier sondern
auch international deshalb steht hier
die Demokratie auf dem
spielam kinger hatte fürump
Amtsenthebung gestimmt gilt als Verräter
weil er nun Joe Biden unterstützt und
vor der Radikalisierung seiner eigenen
der republikanischen Partei warnt
rechtskonservative aus Politik und
Denkfabriken haben unter dem Titel
Mandat zur Führung auch schon die
Blaupause für eine autoritäre
Präsidentschaft aufgeschrieben fast 1000
Seiten mit Plänen für die verschiedenen
Politikbereiche Triebfeder ist die
Heritage Stiftung die rechte Denkfabrik
rekrutiert trumpanhänger um 50.000
Regierungs Mitarbeiter zu ersetzen im
gesinnungstest wird gefragt ob der
Präsident seine Agenda durchsetzen
können sollte ohne dass ihn nicht
gewählte Beamte daran
hind Donald Trump wird wenn er gewinnt
in dieser Amtszeit viel klüger
hineingehen als beim letzten Mal er wird
Leute um sich herum platzieren die ihm
sagen herr Präsident ich stelle sie über
die Verfassung es wir Trump nicht schwer
fallen solche Leute zu
finden wir haben ein Karikaturisten
gebeten die Ausgangslage im Wahljahr zu
verdeutlichen trotz aller Widrigkeiten
spricht demnach einiges auch weiterhin
für eine Wiederwahl Joe bidens vor allem
ist er eben nicht Donald Trump schmiedet
Allianzen weltweit und wirtschaftlich
läuft es auch ziemlich gut das Wachstum
liegt bei fast 5% der Konsum läuft wie
lange nicht die Durchschnittslöhne
liegen höher als vor der coronapandemie
überall neue Jobs die Arbeitslosigkeit
mit 3,8% auf historischen Tiefständen
Amerikas Wirtschaft ist stark aber der
Präsident wirkt schwach zumindest
körperlich deshalb wünschen sich mehr
als 70% der Amerikaner dass der
81-Jährige an jüngere
übergibt warum sollte er Amerika hat die
stärkste Wirtschaft in der Welt unsere
Verbündeten vertrauen uns und wir führen
die Welt als Bollwerk der
Demokratie
warum um Himmels willen sollte jemand
mit dieser Bilanz mit dieser Stufe von
Erfahrung und Führungskraft die Bühne
verlassen wenn er doch so viel Gutes
erreicht hat und noch so viel tun
kann aber nicht nur sein Alter sondern
auch andere Themen ziehen beiden derzeit
runter z.B der Krieg in Gaza die
uneingeschränkte Solidarität für Israel
empört muslimische und arabischstämmige
Wähler in den
USA ich bete dass das in Gaza nicht so
weitergeht wenn doch dann wird das dem
Präsidenten bei der Wahl nicht
helfen seine unerschütterliche
Unterstützung für die Ukraine finden
viele zwar weiter gut aber für neue
waffenhilfen fordern die Republikaner
einen Preis beiden soll den Trump geben
die Grenzen dicht machen das Grundrecht
auf Asyl drastisch
einschränken im Dezember kamen eine
viertel Million Menschen neuer
Rekord bei der Zuwanderung muss Joe
Biden mehr tun wir können ein sehr
mitfühlendes Land sein das waren wir
immer schon aber wir haben ein echtes
Problem an unserer Grenze und er muss
beweisen dass er das ernst
nimmt das fordern auch zwei Drittel
aller Wähler republikanische Gouverneure
lassen ztausende von Zuwanderern in
demokratisch regierte Städte
transportieren Bürgermeister und
Gouverneure von der Demokratischen
Partei rufen den Notstand aus machen
Druck auf beiden und einer nutzt all das
aus um Ängste zu schüren mit
menschenverachtenden
lügen wenn sie 15 bis 16 Millionen
Menschen hereinlassen dann vergiften sie
das Blut unseres
Landes solche Sätze helfen beiden er
kann Donald Trump als Bedrohung stellen
für Amerikas Demokratie für Bürger und
Menschenrechte er nennt seine Gegner
Ungeziefer behauptet das Blut Amerikas
werde vergiftet das ist exakt die
gleiche Wortwahl wie in Nazi
Deutschland was genau sind die Absichten
jenes Mannes seine Pläne für Amerika
wenn schon im Wahlkampf seine Sprache
der von
gleicht unser Karikaturist hat eine
konkrete Vorstellung
davon dieser Herausforderung sieht sich
der amtierende Präsident selbst
gewachsen viele bezweifeln das wohl
deshalb stellt beiden Donald Trump als
größtmögliche Gefahr da damit die Angst
im Stimmen bringt aber diese Angst so
meinen die Experten ist voll und ganz
berechtigt das trifft es genau ich werde
Joe Biden unterstützen denn das
Überleben unseres Regierungssystems ist
viel wertvoller als jeder kleinliche
politstreit den wir in den letzten 100
Jahren hatten und in den nächsten 100
haben
werden dieser Hai bedroht die ganze Welt
denn wenn die Demokratie in Amerika
untergeht wird das die ganze Welt spüren
mit ernsten Folgen rund um den
Globus genau das will Kelly nenhaus
verhindern Amerikaner sollten trotz
aller politischen Differenzen
zusammenarbeiten ich will in 2024 für
eine Präsidentin Stimmen bei der ich
stolz sagen kann dass es meine
Präsidentin ist jemand der die
Vereinigten Staaten wirklich gut
repräsentiert bei der Vorwahl am Montag
soll es hier -20° kalt sein trotzdem
will Kelly zur Wahl gehen seine Stimme
Nicki haly geben um neues Trump Chaos zu
verhindern